let's talk about the section 230 stuff
oh yeah yeah the first thing i want to
do is i want to leave with this
81m.org have you guys seen this have you
heard about this have you seen this no
no
81m 81m.org
tracking the white house youtube channel
oh
yes we were talking about this this is a
great story and it's not
shocking at all i mean it's crazy so
check this out if you go to 81m.org they
say that they're
analyzing the real like to dislike ratio
versus what's displayed on the white
house channel so you'll look right here
check this out
on uh april 5th 14 570 views
the video is titled president biden
delivers remarks on the tradition of
easter at the white house
you can see the official approval rate
according to youtube
is twelve point five eight percent it's
got one thousand five hundred ninety
nine dislikes
the real approval rate is only four
point seven six percent
because it has four thousand six hundred
and six dislikes
this is every single video you can see
that they're deleting dislikes
not nearly enough okay in this one it's
not very it's not much different
some of them are fairly dramatic like
this is a thousand dislikes when there's
four thousand
this one's got twenty 000 dislikes and
youtube claims only a 7 000.
now when i first saw this i thought to
myself how do i know this is true yeah
exactly maybe they're just lying
yeah they could be lying could just be
liars could be liars dirty that's the
story
pants on fire but they also include an
additional metric to compare using the
same data at the end they say trust me
bro yeah
i'm pretty sure they're telling the
truth and come on man come on man come
on man i'm like well i don't know
okay he's got a phone that sounds like
fighting they track pewdiepie
when you look at pewdiepie's like to
dislike ratio it's almost identical
across the board there are some
disparities
but that's because youtube does
legitimately get rid of spam dislikes
from you know bot farms and things like
that
pewdiepie is overwhelmingly no his
numbers are accurate
so when you look at a massive channel
like his then you look at the white
house
it's very strange now again i'll say it
it's possible the people behind eight
behind 81m
are just like giving us bunk numbers and
then claiming that
trump supporters yeah far right is it
81m
yeah.org 1m.org that's possible
yeah maybe they're just lying but uh we
know for a fact that youtube has already
stated in the past they do
remove likes from the white house uh
youtube channel dislike sorry yeah and
they announced that their
uh they announced that they may get rid
of the dislike feature i heard about
this for people's health i like i hope
so because it's bad for my health when i
get a dislike on one of my videos
i wish youtube would come and delete
some of those but you can still see them
it's just other people can't oh
oh that's not good that's not going to
help my health what does that do
didn't they change it to say not for me
instead of a down vote i did say and
you're like
this video kind of video is not for me
and then the algorithm tries to feed you
less videos like that
i thought i saw a screenshot of a
stephen crowder video that said not for
me
instead of dislike huh um i never
disliked since 2007 i kind of made like
a
a personal choice to never do that to
someone i either like it or not
i don't like it i don't say anything i
actually think they should get rid of
uh dislikes really yeah likes and
dislikes
dislikes absolutely do hurt channels
they make sure that other people can't
see the content so what happens is
because crowder brought this up
that they'll put out a video where it's
like joe biden says you know x
and people will go i can't believe joe
biden said that dislike
and then he's like no don't dislike us
just like we agree with you like like
what we're saying
maybe it's possible to adjust the
algorithm so that disliking the video
doesn't result in fewer people viewing
it but
the audience is still able to know what
the general consensus on the video is
yeah you can have like facebook has
little emojis so you can have the angry
emoji yeah the heart emoji the thumbs up
emoji
make it more complicated and they kind
of show like did you did it make you
angry did it make you happy did it make
you laugh so they could use that
algorithm
i've got a really good idea i think this
is the future for youtube they have five
stars
and you can give the video a ranking
zero all at the beginning or five stars
and each video will be somewhere along
the spectrum
why didn't anyone ever try anyone ever
do this yeah it would have been great
they should be doing this since the
beginning
yeah yeah yeah like right when they
started they should have had that system
like before they
before genius yeah yeah why did that
change
honestly i do think like a like dislike
thing is more accurate
than um a star system though because
someone could be like i like this but
like what someone considers four or five
star content is going to vary wildly
between people two people can like
something equally as much but one
person's like this is five stars and the
other person's like three and a half
yeah so i saw a yelp review once where
it was like the restaurant got through a
three-star rating out of five from
someone and they were like this is one
of the best restaurants i've ever been
to
absolutely great three out of five and
then the owner was like
would you mind giving us more stars if
you really liked it that much but it's
because the person thought three out of
five was like
really good four was like wow and five
was too perfect to exist
i found i was on a trip and i booked my
own hotel unfortunately without reading
the reviews
and then when i got there i was like
this place is a little sketchy why don't
i check out the reviews
so i went to the reviews and it was so
horrifically bad
i was like i'm gonna go i'm just gonna
look at the worst first just to see if
this place is dangerous
it was very danger one of the reviews
was like someone was killed here the
night i was staying here
the next day i'm not kidding the next
day someone was shot in the parking lot
i was like okay
and then one of one of the reviews said
it was like listing all these things
that were wrong with the room and it was
like and i found a crack pipe under the
sink
free crack pipe yes it was kind of like
i was fine with the mint on the pillow
but apparently a crab pipe under the
sink is
is the new thing um and the response
from the hotel was
thank you for staying at blanken
i was crying dude i have to i have to
send the screenshots to you because i
was like at this hotel and i was
horrified but i was also laughing really
hard at these reviews i was like
i have to leave like right now this was
in uh this was in georgia
wow yeah bad neighborhood yeah it was it
was in a bad part of town
i should have rather because here's the
thing i looked at the reviews well
here's the thing i so foolishly i booked
it very quickly because it wasn't kind
of a rush mistake
but it said on the website's page most
people who come here
return later so it's like oh it must be
a nice place well it turns out people
who like go to hotels to do like drug
dealers know that nefarious things will
like go to the same hotel a bunch of
times
this place worked i like come back
sorting reviews by
likes or sorting them by dislikes so you
can see like all the dislikes first i
also like sorting by recent
so you can be like what happened
yesterday and the nice thing about steam
first it's like someone gets killed at
the hotel
two days in a row once and all of a
sudden people don't like
steam lets you see how many hours
someone has played a video game before
they rate it
i like kind of get some perspective so
if you knew more about the person that
was giving the rating you might be able
to tell
but then i mean that's more of a complex
algorithm it's funny because then i was
searching for other hotels
and i i found this place and i was like
i'm gonna look at the negative reviews
first just to see and the worst review
was like the attendant was very rude to
me okay
i'm staying here this is great the the
main issue with like the youtube dislike
thing
is that first and foremost the white
house is an official channel
that produces content not as a career
but because they're the white house so
they put out updates so everyone's met
jill biden at the end of his press
conference
like smash that like button he should be
saying that
like share subscribe to the channel
thanks for watching
youtube channel press the like button
could you imagine if he's at a press
conference again and he's talking to the
press corps and he's like
now for all you journalists uh you know
sitting in here you know
we're on youtube so i'm gonna give a
shout out to everybody smash that like
button
don't forget to hit that notification
bell and subscribe we're really close to
breaking one million subscribers so come
on man become a subscriber
holding up his play
yeah at the end there's like an insert
clip where he's like thanks for watching
our youtube channel
just pretty much sure he should do that
biden should do that he would be able to
i'm like all right i admire the hustle
and i've been in his position so i get
it
it's like plugging the federal
government's now running on patreon
they're like try to get
like all right it's got 328.2 million
patrons
no dude it's like half and it's like
it's like so if you if you make this
much money you must subscribe for this
tier to make this much money
and it was like and then in big bold
letters if you don't subscribe we'll
come and arrest you at gunpoint oh my
god
that's how patreon should work right so
listen here's here's the issue i have
with
the dislike button let's say somebody
likes political commentary
and they like subject matter about
whatever
when they give a dislike they actually
like this kind of content yes they
actually like this subject
but they disagree with some something
and it maybe it's the opinion of the
person in an article
maybe it's the opinion of the host but
they do typically enjoy this kind of
content the dislike in that regard
doesn't work because then it results in
fewer people seeing content they would
actually enjoy
so ultimately what i'm saying is if i
make a video where i'm like
i think the government should bring back
government cheese or whatever
yeah people are going to be like bad
opinion x and then what they're really
what what youtube hears
is not i dislike this opinion youtube
hears this video is a bad video
so then there may be people who actually
agree with that opinion and they won't
be served the content
youtube is effectively creating
political silos
where they force people into one or the
other bubble because if you capture a
liberal audience and you say
liberal opinion all the liberals give
you a thumbs up
so then youtube's like share with more
people yeah if you say conservative
opinion and
then and liberals give it a thumbs down
they stop showing it to anybody
then what happens is these people are
forced to choose whichever bubble that
youtube sorts them to it's almost like
you ever see a thing where they have the
conveyor belt with all the little baby
chickens on it
and then they're like picking up and
looking and throwing the mails into the
meat grinder yes
yes basically it's basically like how it
feels getting a dislike
every single one i'm like that's that's
not what i mean what i mean is
you start a new channel right start a
brand new channel
and say my opinion on immigration
whichever person that youtube randomly
suggests that video to assuming they do
if their opinion is liberal and they
give you a thumbs up then youtube's
going to start growing your channel
if they send it to a conservative and
your opinion is liberal your channel
your channel's crushed but
in addition to that like you said you'll
you'll make a video you'll say these
people got murdered and tortured and the
person will be like thank you
so much for making this video and
telling me about it that's horrible that
they got murdered thumbs
that's down because it's important for
people to remember that that the like
and dislike button is not there for you
to assess whether you're happy with
what's being reported on it's there to
bully
creators with bad opinions absolutely
yeah that's what we have noticed
or just ugly ones yeah like me yeah
exactly every time i'm on the dislike
ratio you guys just get ratio it's super
hard i'm like why is this ugly
exactly did you know i need a haircut
badass they look you should throw it out
you afro that thing
you know it's built for it what really
bothers me the most though
is that people aren't smashing the like
button for this hand smashing
smash that like button we're almost at a
million subscribers
we're gonna get the the plaques but not
even for the plaque i want the plaque
guys if we don't get if we don't get how
many how many likes do you get on
average
we get like 12 no if we don't get 15 000
likes i'm deleting freedom tunes
oh right now all tomorrow smash that
like button well no this this resulted
in a genre of videos
that were literally just smash the like
button videos
where it was really funny there'd be
like a guy and he'd be like
hey everybody what's going on we're
going to smash that like button the
camera like zooms in on his face back
and forth and there's like explosions
and it's like five million likes and
it worked because youtube would prop
those videos up so then people just
started doing that
that's that's it i love that i mean
people will always find a way to mess
with the rules everyone's always trying
to get away with something at all times
yeah sometimes you'll be like and go
ahead and smash that and they'll have
like low energy but like you gotta like
it's more like
the build up like you can say tap that
like button but if you say it with like
vehemence you know then it gets people
to tap it dude that like here's
the energy then that happens sometimes
because like there are some videos i i
end up having to pull an all-nighter in
order to finish and then i don't record
the bumper until right before i upload
so the video is like really high energy
and crazy and then i'm like
guys please like share subscribe and hit
the like button
if you can't yeah exactly then i'm like
stumbling over my words i literally
become joe biden when i don't have
enough sleep
you know the button the thing maybe they
should get rid
or alter up thumbs up to say like show
me more of this because on facebook
that's what it does
would you like to know more button yeah
click here if you'd like to know more at
the end would you like to there
shouldn't be a like or dislike once the
video ends
it should go would you like to know more
and it just appear and you can click it
that's it with facebook would you like
to know more about what the specific
video
from this from this person
i didn't realize like over my head i'll
go down the list and i'll i'll see
things from people that i like following
and i don't even care what they
put but i'll just like it because i want
to see more from that person so i've
broken the out i've seen
passed through the algorithm can we get
3 000 likes for ian breaking the
algorithm like looking past it i like it
absolutely so apparently if on facebook
you post
that you have have a kid and got married
it'll appear on the top of
all of your friends feeds and so what
people started doing for a while is
they'd post like
just got married and had a had a new
child so excited
anyway none of that's true i want to let
you know that i'm having a barbecue in
my mind
people are doing the algorithm found out
that people
interacted the most with posts about
marriage and having kids yeah and
everyone's like love it
they're all commenting and thumbs up so
they get boosted
and then the algorithm makes no sense
shameful tim
that's fraud thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have
full bonus episodes thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time
you